foreign
let's go to Northern Oklahoma or as some
call it Canada let's talk to Matthew
what's up Matthew
hey Dr John how you doing today great
how about you man
I'm doing phenomenal this is unreal it's
great to be here thank you so much man
what's up how can I help
that guy let's let's jump into the let's
just jump right onto into it here so
really here's the quick setup I mean I
listen to you almost every day while I'm
at work as long as well as the Rams are
showing and you've really helped me in a
lot of areas of my life and I just I see
how many people you help
um so hey I thought you know maybe you
can help me too so let's bring it on
thank you man what's up you betcha so my
goal really with this call is really
just to try and get some answers and
solve solve some of the problems here
um that I may be facing personally and
and specifically in my relationship so
I'm looking to solve problems in my
relationship
um you know how do I know I'm dating the
right person and how do I bridge this
gap between my myself and my partner in
in this relationship so what happened
that precipitated this call
so I I mean here's the setup right so
I'm I'm 28 years old my partner's a bit
older than me she's 31. we've been
dating on and off here really for the
last six years and and I've lost track
now how many times we've broken up and
gone back together I think it's three
um fast forwarding to today we we
recently bought a house together we've
been living together here for the last
six months and and really a part of me
feels like I'm sometimes just just slim
too sometimes things are really great
and I go you know wow this is this is
awesome I'm really enjoying life and
we're out doing stuff and and things are
blast and other times I'm just you know
I catch myself just thinking what have I
gotten myself into and I can start you
know catching myself gearing up to ways
to get out of this and it's really just
disoriented me and it's exhausting and
I'm trying to I really I really want
things to work I think overall and and
it's just we've been having these we'll
have dumb arguments really about nothing
that I just come home and they'll just
leave me wiped out so can I ask you some
real direct direct like just cut to the
chase questions
let's do it absolutely if I did this in
person it would feel insulting so I'm
just gonna go at it okay
that's fine let's let's jump into it is
your girlfriend nuts
and hey it only works if you tell the
truth when you get home does she start
crap with you and start fights with you
and tell you that you're stupid and
you're dumb and you don't do this right
like what are the what's the nature of
these fights no I'll tell you so it's
it's I don't I don't think she's nuts
and really how do you define nuts
anyways it's oh I've got some pretty
clear I work with Kelly I I know very
just kidding
what do you think okay I wrote down some
examples because I figured this was
going to come up so here's an example
like I've got a great career I'm doing
really well in life and as an athlete
and I'll come home
um from a busy day at work
um you know I get home and I just want
to throw some I I'll throw some clothes
on the on the bedroom floor and then go
jump in the shower and then I'm a guy
sometimes I forget about them and then
I'll go off and do some other things
make a smoothie go outside sit on my
patio and you know then it's hey you
know what you got to clean these clothes
up do this or or you know the last fight
we just had I'll give you another
example is we'll be fighting about a
utility bill for example and it's like
she's like hey the the bill costs fifty
dollars more this month why is that I'm
just my kind of thought was it is hey
it's a utility bill it's just money it's
fifty dollars like money
money is not the issue here where you
know it's not it's not a problem but so
here's the issue I can tell you right
now okay
twofold
number one have you heard me talk about
pictures and words here
pictures and words have you heard me
talk about that on my show
uh no okay the great William Glasser
said that he could fix most marriage
issues in one to two sessions
and I rolled my eyes and he said 99 I
made that number up a significant
percentage of marriage issues
is a mismatch between pictures and words
what do I mean
when you and your wife or you and your
girlfriend bought this house
you both use the word let's buy a house
together you both said let's make a home
in her picture of home
is straight out of Pinterest
and she grew up in a house where I'm
making something up here so maybe a way
off but just go with me
where
her mom got beat up for not having a
clean house or her mom cleaned the house
and she saw her dad look at her mom and
say thank you so much for loving me so
much I'm really grateful
or maybe her dad sucked and threw crap
all over the place and she heard her mom
whisper I wish she just showed me enough
respect to clean up his stupid underwear
and then that is wrapped into her
picture of home forget the words picture
and your picture of home
looks like a place where you can after
being on all day every day you can just
drop your shoulders throw your stuff on
the floor kick your feet up because ah
I'm here
you both love each other
you both want to make a great home you
both just have a different picture of
what that looks like
and so you find yourself in these weird
fights about clothes and about TV
channels and about forty dollars extra
on a light bill
it has nothing to do with it at all it
has to do with your wife is desperately
trying to create this picture of this
home she has in her head and this life
she has in her head and you both are
using the same words the joke I use when
I talk about this from stage is my wife
comes out and says hey let's go on a
really hot hot date this weekend it's
going to be smoke show and I start
thinking what hotel we're going to end
up at in what city and what we're going
to be wearing and for how long and for
her hot date is the Burrito Barn has
tacos for a dollar on this Friday night
I love tacos and she likes romantic
Rendezvous but both of us end up mad
when we finally realize that we're not
doing the other thing that the other
person thought has nothing to do with
what we want or what we intention has to
do with how we discuss what's this world
we're creating together I'm also going
to give you this picture and this is
just from the data okay it's just from
research this isn't me preaching at you
it's hard to play house and also anchor
into a stable relationship that's been
off and on for six years
and so some of the frenetic energy you
feel in the house is a body your wife's
body and your body trying to regulate
the realities of living together which
is hard
and also
trying to live together and do hard
things without being fully anchored in
the ground
because when you buy a house together
but you're not married you don't you
don't legally bind this thing together
the idea is but I could leave
nah but I could leave
and that plays havoc on each other so
I'm going to tell you my wife and I
dated five years we broke up five times
twice it was a forever breakup
and we'll celebrate 21 years this summer
of being married
here's what it came down to
largely me saying I'm gonna go all in
I'm gonna Choose You
as the woman I'm going to commit the
rest of my life to and that choice is
going to be every day and it's not out
of a movie it's not the notebook wasn't
true like Titanic wasn't true I wish it
was man but it wasn't
and I'm going to commit to you and I've
almost blown it up a couple of times
over 21 years it's not gonna be perfect
and it's gonna be messy
but I choose you and that means I'm not
going to say stupid stuff like uh you
know I'm just a guy so I don't pick up
my underwear pick up your underwear
I'm saying
you sitting down and telling her hey
here's our financial picture
let's do this together so that if a
light bill comes in 40 bucks over
we smile about it it's it doesn't wreck
our life
I grew up in a home Matt that
um
forty dollars an un on like a forty
dollar bill that came in unexpectedly
took away took food off our table was
was tragic
right so I am it's extra attuned to that
even now
it just kind of wired into me so my wife
has to constantly John we have enough
we're good we're good we're good I can
look at the numbers I can see the
numbers I know we're good intellectually
my body still says that water bill is
like whatever it is right so I just
threw a lot at you
what do you think
I I agree with that and I I you know
like I said I I've heard you say I'm a
long time listen I've I've heard you say
you know you got to be all in and and I
completely agree with that I think or
any relationship to review who do you
have to be all in and I think the where
I'm running into problem and where I'm
running out of steam is is when we come
home and and I've you know I've said
sorry yeah I want this I want to be all
in with you and I like it and I I'll
come home and it'll just be a fight
it'll be something and then I can just I
can figure myself gearing up and I'm
going oh my God and I I'm running out of
this theme of of just commitment to you
because we just have to keep dealing
with what keeps going on here and it's
it's driving me crazy and I would I do
agree with that yeah I'm happy to clean
up the clothes yeah you know life is
about negotiations and I'm all good with
that and I've been trying to do a better
job with that but listen don't don't
negotiate the details yet
negotiate the pictures
and that starts with this question over
a breakfast and I think at some point
you all been together 60 years so I
think calling this out
we bought a house together we are all
but married
I want to spend the rest of my life with
you and I can't continue to live in a
home where there's fights that escalate
like these do all the time
foreign
and so here's what the question I want
to ask you honey who I love
what kind of home do we want to build
because we get to choose that
what do we want our life to look like
and where this is scary is she might say
I want it to look like this and you know
in your soul I can't do that or I don't
have any interest in that
and I also have friends who dated five
six seven years that ended up breaking
up and marrying other people that's
brutal and it's devastating it's hard
but it was right
but you can only get there if you're
willing to own reality to choose reality
I love you we have a home together we've
been together for half more than half a
decade and I can't take another month of
these fights
are you willing to build a new life with
me
and really that's you dude is being as
vulnerable as possible because she can
look at you and say no
that's scary right
yeah
scary so let me ask you this what if I
told you just break up with her dude be
done
does that give you peace just be done
man you've put in six years it's not
working call it
foreign
I can breathe a little bit here
and Another Part Of Me would be
absolutely crushed because I know that I
do how much I feel how much I love this
woman and um yeah how I feel about her
I think that's the question to explore
that you've got to be honest with
yourself about
great I also don't believe and
I know some of the the marriage
Instagram gurus are gonna come out of
the woods on me for this but I don't
believe that it's a hundred like I just
knew without a shadow of it I dude I
don't know a lot of people who had No
Reservations I don't know those people
but I know that when it works it's when
people say despite the reservations
despite the
come what may I'll be right here
the commitment is on me
yeah
that's scary and hard man
sir yeah how do you enter out
well I mean
are you in or out in or out do it say it
yeah yeah exactly I want to be in I I
want to be in and I really want to make
this work and I do want this because I
see us building a really great life
together okay and and but but stuff has
to change that's where I'm at with it I
love it stuff has to change so I want
you I want you to write this those
things down and I want you to spend as
little time on the details as possible
and when you write these down this is
critical for you and anybody listening
to this
when you sit down and have take her to
breakfast and it's gonna be a two or
three hour Affair and some little
Canadian Bistro I don't even know if
that's a thing that I just made that up
here's here's the conversation it has to
be all about you
what do I mean by that if you sit down
and say I just come home and I drop my
clothes and you're doing this and you're
doing this and you're doing this
then she's got to go to war with you
but if you sit down and say
I have a picture of my home that is warm
and safe
and I'm I'm out at work all the time and
I come home and I just drop my shoulders
and then I feel like I disappoint you
and you get upset that I've left
underwear and I'm tired of being I'm
tired of feeling like a disappointment
in my own home
or the water bill comes in it's 40 more
expensive than we thought it was going
to be
I know how much money we make you know
how much money we make and I feel like
I'm failing you because I haven't
provided a safe home for my my future
wife
you see how you aren't attacking you are
saying here's how I feel
that's much more inviting so I want you
to take the time to write down on a
piece of paper
how you're feeling which is like ill
gross
take the things that are pissing you off
take the things that make you mad and
there's I know there's a list of things
that you are courteous enough not to
have aired your dirty laundry on a
podcast that's fine
but I want you to be honest about those
things and don't go start throwing darts
at this at this time together I want you
to say here's how this here's how I am
impacted by this
here's what makes me nervous here's what
makes me excited about moving forward
here are some things you do that make
the house feel like this
we got it we gotta own reality we gotta
choose reality and start from there
I actually have some pretty high hopes
for this relationship because I think
you love this girl I think she probably
loves you and I think six years is a
long time to put two people in a cage
and be like make good choices
without you start just gnawing each
other's tail off
have this conversation hey please do me
a huge favor I'm kind of invested in
this now reach out and let me know how
that how that breakfast goes how that
time together goes I want to hear how it
goes and we'll be rooting for you every
step of the way my brother